travis bergen makes his first big league
start two and one now
ground ball this should be two
the chef to panic back to first double
play
nice job by travis vergan he gets the
ball on the ground the blue jays turn to
double play
no harm no foul the error does not
factor in we'll go to the bottom of the
first no score here in dunedin
charlie morton is all warmed up and
ready to go
the [ __ ] that's gonna drop for a base
hit another two strike base hit charlie
morton is somewhat predictable when he
gets to two strikes
51 percent of the time he'll throw you
that curveball
strike over the outside corner that's
not where charlie wanted it but it had
the plate
[Applause]
there's a base hit to right field
the shed will stop at
second as acuna has one of the best arms
in baseball again the runners will be
off to the races the pitch breaking ball
is cut on a miss so charlie gives up two
hits but picks up two strikeouts as well
so dansby swanson hits with sunset
approaching in dunedin well he's worked
it full here with two outs
pablo sand of all the braves d-h on deck
the 3-2 count
and a line drive into left field a base
hit so that snaps dansby's old for 11.
and that's the first atlanta hit
[Applause]
and it's right back up the middle of
bay's head
so sandoval has his first hit
right-handed the braves have
back-to-back hits with two outs and
that'll bring up austin riley with two
aboard
[Applause]
little dribbler up the third base line
and malone can't pick it up cleanly
and atlanta's got the bases loaded for
christian pache two men out two-two
pitch coming so you're gonna high fly to
deep left field way back
way back it's the grandest of all home
runs
christian popjay welcome back
now you've got springer bushette and
guerrero to deal with with a man aboard
nobody out
deep drive to ride get up ball get out
of here and go george springer gets the
green light and goes apple for his first
home run as a blue jay
jays are right back in it
yeah he can jog now he doesn't have to
try and beat out an infield hit he can
just jog around the bases he had kirk
down two strikes and then three straight
misses walked him fell behind george
springer
and they give him the green light and
he unloads and cuts that lead in half
with one swing
70 pitches out of morton one two on the
way goodbye swung on and missed
that's a one two three bottom of the
fourth inning
and now ron lacuna junior is going to
lead off
that is rifle to left a line drive homer
off the netting and acuna has extended
the braves lead
that had a vapor trail behind it that
thing was crushed arnold's ninth long
ball of the year and it's five to two
braves
wow
no balls at a strike on travis star no
pitch on the way he shoots one out to
center that's down for a base hit
playing it on a hop randall grichik
advancing one station ozzy all bees
[Applause]
two two two outs we're gonna miss
swanson strikes out and the braves will
leave two runners in scoring position
5-2 game
and this one on the ground riley
bare hand might have a shot and
did
he didn't give up on the play after
bobbling once with the glove once with
the hand and he made a strike to first
to get alejandro kirk nice play
yes good job of staying with that
and you need all the stars to align
sometimes for a play like that and
thankfully he had to catch
it hurry
they call him out and i don't know if he
was out pasha can fly
the braves are going to look at it and
walt wise the bench coach and they want
to look at it and they're going to take
a
review
jerry meows the third base umpire is the
crew chief
the first base umpire made the call paul
clements and i'll tell you what he was
flying
so this this should be an easy call
[Applause]
indeed it is
so the call on the field is uphill
sandoval
walked to start do you think austin
riley was hit by a pitch and acuna this
could be too
panic to second for one back to first it
is a double play what a job by tim mason
[Applause]
looking inside the blue jays dugout
we've got a wardrobe change danny jansen
who did not start this game behind the
plate is wearing the full catcher gear
and alejandro kirk who he saw pull up on
that long foul drive with something in
his left leg is now sitting on the bench
without any catcher gear looks like
there's an injury
so one out now here's randall grichik
there's a base hit past riley into right
field guerrero's getting the wave around
ozuna doesn't have an arm at all so he
scores easily
corey rivera waved guerrero around the
moment that ball hit ground in left
field then gritschick picks up an rbi
that's his 18th of the season and it's a
two-run game
even things up here they trailed by two
the braves have out hit the blue jays
nine to five
all five braves
runs have scored on home runs
oh and one
that's a base hit inside the bag kay
oscar's coming around third he's going
to score grichik is headed to third
they're going to wave him home here's
the throw from swanson plenty of time
and he is out
instead of second and third with one out
now 5-4 runner at third with two outs
travis dorneau may have injured his left
hand on the tag at the plate
so alex jackson has been watching the
game with sal fasada the braves catching
coordinator
and he's gonna have to come into the
game now with the tying run at third
base and two outs
one out george springer will come to the
plate
[Music]
swinging the drive he's done it again
springer on a 3-0 pitch this was nine
miles
and we are
tied knew as soon as he touched it off
[Applause]
so kevin will
be given the free pass that'll load the
bases and bring randall grichik to the
plate
there's a nice hit
[Music]
singles into center espionage comes in
to score and the blue jays walk off the
braves